hello everyone welcome to part five of
my resident evil village playthrough
um where i'm a bit scared to leave this
room because
she sure is right out there
she's just right she's right there
um i
feel like i've made some mistakes here
there are areas that i think i do need
to go search there was this upstairs
area that i realized
i was in the hall of joy but i oh my god
but i missed this door i should have
unlocked it but i went upstairs first so
i think that i probably do need to do
some doubling back
to clear some of this stuff out at this
point um
which is okay i guess because i am
looking for the final
mask anyway which is going to be
oh is it this one no i think we've got
that hang on which mask do we have
mask of rage mask of joy and we got the
mask of sorrow so
the last one is going to be the mask of
what um
the hall of pleasure
we have to go through well we have to go
back to her dressing room
okay is what does that mean
uh i probably have that key by now
surely but that's actually
oh my dude shut up um that's probably
not that hard to do i feel like i just
want to go through some of this outdoor
stuff first
she really sounds like she's right there
okay um so where where do we want to
head to like i feel like right now i
want to go through the main hall out the
dining room and then go to here
just to get everything covered which i
thought about not doing while you guys
are watching i thought about doing it
like
just separately so nobody has to watch
it but then what if she shows up you
know
so we're just gonna see if she's out
here
yep she sure [ __ ] is
she's certainly in the vicinity
somewhere
not entirely sure oh there you are love
hello
she's just so cute though oh i want to
see you walk down those stairs i don't
mind if this kills me
look at you
just a work of art just just a work of
art
look at her strut in it
yeah i was actually just trying to check
you out i don't know if you should take
that as an insult but i understand that
everyone
you know has different reactions to
being hit on not everybody likes it i
get that
i apologize if you took it as an insult
i'm just trying to go
back out here okay she's not hard to get
away from
we're gonna go here i think for now
because i think i've done everything
over this way i didn't because i have to
go back to the library as well
which would mean going through to the
offer hole should i do that first
because that'll take me back to the main
hall and then come out and do this side
i think maybe i should
so that's just go up this way
and i don't really think there's going
to be much going on game's still very
dark
um it's just
though i may have left some some some
dead dudes up here i don't remember
it's just a matter of uh and i didn't
know that i could break the glass last
time i was here
um i'm just inspecting stuff a little
bit better
oh please be where the mistresses
lipstick is missing if anyone finds it
could they please return it to a
bathroom i wonder if that will tie into
the mention earlier of the poison
they're gonna be being poisoned with her
own lipstick
okay damn nice all right i already find
a lot of stuff we miss
i can't get through those she's coming
out here too
dude
maybe that's not her maybe it's
unrelated
um okay i know there was a lockpick
thing that i'm pretty sure i have in my
inventory now that i did not
get lost time do this
yeah what
what do you mean i tried to use the pipe
bomb
that would be a little bit excessive
cool is that everything yes
uh okay so we're gonna go
through the library again
okay this isn't actually taking anywhere
near as long as i thought that it would
um libraries this way
i did didn't i no
how to get to library it's upstairs and
then through the other door is that what
that's saying
that did i do that was that me hello hi
this one's the library
yes okay so oh no
no no no no
it sounds like she's so [ __ ] close
but maybe she's not maybe the game is
wrong
you know i'm just in here
trying to find any loot that i might
have missed
they are loud footsteps
no that's not it okay there's more
oh i'm good okay okay
[ __ ] hell
the music i don't know what else to look
for in here um
is this maybe not a good time to do this
because
you know she she seems upset
it's [ __ ] it's fine she could be ages
away it's fine it's fine it's fine
we're just looking for anything we've
missed in here is it that
yeah okay
i'm gonna go through a hall of joy which
is this way
okay
this seems good i think it was maybe
just that she was
she's probably just out here right and
just i'm just hearing it
she's probably just in the main hall
not mommy you might hear anyone
mommy
can't see [ __ ] she's around though she's
around
um so that's all done main hall we have
not yet cleared out
and i still want to go back to there
she's in the main hall for sure
and then i did want to go back to this
area too should i do that first maybe
i feel silly i feel like i should go
through the main hall
my love light of my life
queen
okay the amount of times that i've
walked down this exact hallway
my princess my sweet my sweet angel
oh my god holy [ __ ]
why did they choose then to
oh [ __ ] me the music had just died down
you know and i didn't
[ __ ] hell
see i didn't think you'd come out here
because it's cold it's cold
you don't like it where it's cold you'll
make the best vintage
oh god oh my god this didn't go
according to plan at all excuse me let
me just pull up my map
okay i'm just trying to go to the right
we're just trying to go to the right
we're just kind of trying to just trying
to go to the right
and i'm not taking anybody with me
okay goodbye goodbye you
stay outside
please stay outside please please
no no no no it sounds like she's right
behind me again
[ __ ] hell
oh
oh convenient cool
[ __ ]
the directional audio
is just so intense
that i just [ __ ] hell
it's so stressful i cannot tell if she's
a million miles away or right here
there we go hey don't be mad queen
how did i fit through that oh my god um
well we've figured out everything in
here it's just this bit
i don't know again i don't know if she's
miles away or literally right here
seems okay
who the [ __ ] knows
well okay so this whole area i need to i
need to explore
which is fine
where though but where but where are you
though
boxing dude oh my god
nothing she's not around
she could be ages away [ __ ] hell
oh
is that it nope okay
close that see if there's anything else
around oh i did already grab that
how about you anything
oh there we go cool that beautiful we've
done it okay so i got the lipstick is
that going to be in
key items oh
it's not oh i really would have thought
we had to use that
okay it's just going to be the regular
tentacle boss fight that i expected then
is it
great quick quick quick quick cool cool
cool cool
and then yeah what we're just gonna go
that first room has not been explored
everything else in this area is looking
pretty good that one i need another
lockpick which i haven't seen for a bit
can i buy them maybe i'm not sure
okay
again woman i really am trying to open
all the windows
just in case
my queen my love light of my life
can't see you but and i feel like i
would be able to
is the thing is like she's
pretty [ __ ] visible oh it's it's down
then it's not up here
so what is that sound
i think she's just in the courtyard
maybe
and the music is having a heart attack
because of proximity
because she's close even if you're
upstairs which is very confusing
okay i'll find something
down here right yeah
hmm
is that it beautiful
she's probably gonna be right out there
where should i go from here
i can't go back to the bed chamber i
kind of want to go back to the merchant
to see if i can buy
the lock pick and then it's just to
there right so okay we're gonna go to
the merchant
through the courtyard through the dining
room through the main hall just back to
the magic
full loop baby
hey hello
i know i should run but i really do like
looking at home
there is though there's a couple of
places that i could run
and i think this is the right way
let me just go through here through here
and then avoid plugging bug [ __ ]
showing up
she'll also show up okay
okay okay okay
beautiful okay do you have a lot of
pictures i'd choose something for you
no i prefer to choose no one picks
a damn shame um i could sell that
i don't know that i want to right now
i'm going to keep it for a bit
pay me no mind okay we're also just
going to save because we've done some
good work out here
and assume she can't teleport i don't
actually know she could teleport
i don't know which one this is i didn't
check
negative well it's gonna be one of the
two of them
and this one's gonna be this one
beautiful okay
so it is one long pick that i don't have
which is
really it really is killing me it is a
huge bummer
it's the dining room
the courtyard no i should go main hall
upstairs and then through here that's
where i should go let's just go check
the dining room
she's so close to it though is the
problem you know what i'm saying
did she just open that door was that you
my love
wait am i alive baby baby girl
you like are you around here somewhere
is that you
where is it nothing
i think the music's probably gonna get
pretty upset when i
come to here but she's not in here she's
not in here
okay we're just trying to find something
in here to loot
it's still so dark
it's not that
break that while we're at it because why
not
no i did know that that happened okay
does this have any rules or anything
queen
hello here we go
is it one of those glint ones again
maybe that i keep missing
oh it is great
just just chill out okay i'll be with
you in a minute
there's that done okay let's go back
i think she's still outside trying
to walk up my ass i don't know what i'm
supposed to do about you
because i don't oh [ __ ] oh well i okay
i disagree oh [ __ ] what are you gonna do
what you can do about it
what are you gonna do about it it's your
once enemy
a table
yeah i could do this all day
look at the way she looks at me you know
it's just
i just find anyone even look at me the
way she's looking at me right now
damn like this is actually pretty
pleasant she's beautiful
i'm going to leave though because i
don't feel like it's a good use of time
so i'm just going to leave i'm going to
go upstairs i'm going to hook bug [ __ ]
doesn't come back and ruin my day
jesus sounds like everyone's [ __ ] on
top of me
um can anything here be looted maybe any
can you do you have anything that i like
could maybe take
at all it doesn't seem like it um
okay this is where we're supposed to go
maybe for now we just take the l on the
main hall because it's it's hot
you know it's spicy there is too much
going on straight through
this is already i got everything hit
yeah okay cool
let's go it's gonna be
key
okay that's the last mosque
all right
why does it sound like she's so [ __ ]
close again
jesus christ okay
that's gotta be something i can inspect
surely
nothing oh hmm
maybe that can be combined with
something
no interesting okay we'll figure it out
all right
last piece of mask
okay
i feel like i'm probably alright for now
i don't think i'm gonna be attacked here
the armory please have something good
and not just bits of armor
okay this is too much
ammo you're gonna make me fight bug
[ __ ] number three in here on you
what's the scuttering is it flames or is
it
my doom i was worried my sisters had
gotten too
first okay hello um
okay oh god that was fast
yeah yeah yeah okay okay let me just
move this real quick
is that's going to make you cold i think
it's going to help make you a bit colder
you could break it up with a powerful
attack um hang on hang on hang on hang
on
everybody's chill out for a second give
me my pipe bomb
okay let's let's go come
on can we still help okay cool
now ethan we don't hurt you a bit there
bud
crap a little bit more and i'm just
gonna take another one of these
good i'm glad you suck
yo she ran at me oh oh oh that's
sort of new oh my oh you're speedy
oh oh oh oh gosh
why well i mean you're trying to kill me
i i would have thought that that was
nope i thought it blocked out
i'm not blocking enough in this game
okay no
you've got to be close to dying it's
well it's not though
yeah you got to be close you got to be
close that's got to
okay anything anything anything anything
oh
great that's gotta be it it is okay what
just opened
okay you want me to go back okay
so as soon as i put the last one in
we're gonna have to fight it right so
what i need to do here is
is is clear out that main hall is that
all that's left
the main hall in the courtyard and and
the tasting room but there was that
treasure map
wherever that is
not in here um because i am interested
in
whatever that was treasure map
dungeon kitchen treasure
i think i want to do that before we go
any further i think we start just by
heading to the kitchen
if this doesn't trigger something the
minute i get out of here
oh i can't get out this way maybe i put
the mask back for a second
damn okay
well putting the moss back it does open
the door
is there a time situation i can grab it
take it and run no hmm
do i have anything else i could put in
there we go
that's gonna be it great okay cool
so let me put the animal skull here
i should be able to get out with these
ethan's voice came back there's
uh there's a bug why sometimes you can't
hear anything he says
um okay you go downstairs
dining room kitchen okay
big lady hello
hey you think you're going to be very
unhappy with me and what i've just done
oh my god well
okay that's good for me actually keep
going
such a beautiful walk you know i just
want to reiterate that
still wondering if there's anything i
can find in here
what do you swear to god we know that's
empty a lot of you've looked through it
a million times oh there it is
missed it right there
i think she's still downstairs
all right beautiful this is what we like
to see
[ __ ] the entire what am i supposed to do
about when you're here
by the likes of you no no
no no [ __ ] alana
this is bad this is bad we've done bad
here i can't go anywhere from here
[ __ ] okay fine yeah come through come
through
we'll do the dance if we have to
pretty lady hello
you want to hang out
you don't want to hang out i don't trust
this for a [ __ ] second
i'm just going to run
there she is the entire bloody
man that's how you pronounce it
i could just circle around this way i
could just go through here and then go
back
like through this way and then you know
just run away from my problems
like the champion i am you know you can
just have the main hall i don't need to
[ __ ] go to the main
hall what am i going to do there
i don't need it
did she just say something
we go out
dining room kitchen
well see now i probably am walking kind
of closer towards her
right oh wait isn't it this way isn't
this the kitchen
yeah okay um
the [ __ ] is all this
oh my god okay it's fine
so i think this is gonna take me back to
the dungeons to be fair which
maybe isn't so bad because there was a
bunch of [ __ ] down here
so it looked like a pathway like
i think i just have to keep going i
don't think it's going to be on a top
level here somewhere
i'll just keep moving
i feel like in the immediate she is not
nearby oh this is where
i fought the first sister
didn't i get stuck here though i think i
did i don't think oh okay
disregard
okay um that's all right i don't mind
killing you
i'm not afraid of you anymore
you were initially terrifying but now
you're just a bunch of babies it is
still
very dark though which is a concern
how are you alive no you can't live
through that every time
such a betrayal oh
you gotta be dead too i know the rules
directional audio
it's so nice though i was so scared when
i first go oh [ __ ]
good timing oh i was gonna say i was so
scared when i first came down here and
now i'm
champion well i might get my um other
lock pick down here
just leave me alone i hear you growing
out of the ground thinking
you deserve to have a say just because
you're alive
but i disagree
uh oh what's this that's the thing that
i couldn't have before because i don't
have that key that's probably where i'm
supposed to go
let's take a look around shall we on i'm
out here with a lockpick agenda
still so [ __ ] dark just out here
trying to lockpick it
cool
okay um gonna be another fire puzzle
probably am i going to light these
this way
oh disregard i need to light them with a
pipe bomb
that's gonna be pipe bombed
interesting oh okay that's totally what
i was supposed to do
but that might be an easter egg it's
definitely just the actual thing i'm
supposed to do
can i move this maybe it seems far away
i do not think i can
cool negative okay we just need to push
it
get [ __ ] closer but come on a little bit
closer
there you go okay and then go over to
this one
it's amazing he doesn't get burnt
i guess he's sort of a superhero at this
point
putting his hands back on with chem
fluid
come on this shouldn't be this hard and
i'm just gonna swing this back
come on man okay there we go
um oh that's it am i gonna
get stuck here or something
hmm that's just to be sold
do i put it in the ring
anything now
nope and then yeah these still can't be
combined i wondered if they could but
no nothing else in here can be combined
with anything
all right well that's that done cool
i'm just i'm gonna do it i'm just gonna
do it okay we're gonna go we're gonna go
here and we're gonna do it
it's gonna be fine
maybe i'll edit this out if it's super
boring and it's just me looking for
items
so you guys don't have to watch it
at this point i'm just gonna manually
increase brightness you know what it's
going to make everything else look bad
but what if we just
oh it looks so like
bad quality though that's a shame i
don't these brightness settings man
this just ruins the quality a ton but
that's original that's a bit brighter
it'll help
until hopefully there's a patch for it
um
which yeah could happen
this just looks real bad
um okay did i leave anyone else alive in
here i don't think i did i think i got
everyone
but that's a lot of noise so maybe not
all right i went through got everything
i will cut that out because it was just
me looking for tiny items
which is very boring um now it's just
the courtyard
and there's one thing that needs to be
lot picked then i think i might have to
just take the l
on at this point because
i think it was maybe a lock pick that i
needed to find in the
town before
so i'm gonna try and find whatever's in
the courtyard
which i can't get to yeah i have to go
through the dining room
and then i'm gonna put the lost mosque
in
she's gonna be out here isn't she i feel
like i should go save again though
can we just do that and then come back
out
oh god yeah i'm gonna save just because
i cleared that out you know
let's just run for it what could go
wrong
seems like she might be in the courtyard
based on all them sounds
this is all i'm saying i'm just gonna
save
yes uh i have some stuff i can sell you
my good side
window shop away you can take
five of these two of these
one of those i don't think i want to get
rid of that right now
oh nice wait i have a lockpick
i thought i used it hang on hang on
let me make sure i didn't put that up i
didn't okay that means that i do have it
for some reason just trustworthy fair
exchange i was just thinking i didn't oh
my god i
look forward to seeing the fruit you
wish to make a purchase
excellent what else do we want right now
i could take one of these i suppose
we're just going to go with this one
because it's more expensive
boom oh we can afford both
just cashed me up that'll help for
fighting i'm skilled at all sorts
my beautiful queen my beautiful perfect
queen okay
so now we're gonna go
up that way back to that bed chamber
come again
open that thing and then to the
courtyard i'm sure this is very boring
to watch
it's just it's not necessary but i can't
help it at this point
this is the thing we lockpick great
beautiful and then it's just something
in the courtyard
which i feel like i've looked really
thoroughly which makes me think it's
going to be another thing that i have to
shoot
um which yeah i only figured out like
halfway through playing this damn game
in the first place
and she's probably out there if she's
not out there
she's out there isn't she
sweet angel baby my love
queen you i'm just trying to find it
like one thing
i'm actually if anything doing you a
favor with all this tidying i'm doing
you know oh this does suck
then i'm just like why don't you just
look around for something i guess
am i broken all these windows i think i
have right
yeah they're broken okay um
it's not on the ground you just need to
look for [ __ ] where are you where are
you are you i hear you here she says
something when she sees me i'll be fine
i need to look for
something
i'm really surprised it's not this
because this thing just looks so
purposeful but what's the thing that's
creaking
because that would indicate it wants
attention
is there anything blowing on you
not that i can see
what is the creaking thing
baby girl are you you trying to hang out
queen beloved
could you make your mind up you're
losing points of being indecisive
what is that [ __ ] creaking sound oh
oh it's got to be this
it's gold surely that's it
oh okay all right oh my god that's gotta
be it
okay we've done it back inside
straight down here beautiful very stoked
it actually technically was related to
the birds i don't know if that sound
design was trying to help me to the
extent that i thought that it was
but i'm happy about it queen
i love you i would never betray you the
light of my life
all right
who doesn't have a face you do not have
a face that's it let's go
okay
i've done that's going to be unlocked i
think maybe is what's happened here
excuse me a moment just going to save
i think i save more than i need to
beautiful
okay cool
a lot of sounds happening
there we go you want to come say hi what
uh
okay
hmm is this where we trying to have a
final engagement
did i not get everything in this room
there's more stuff more looting to do
i'm not letting it sail now we are 100
in this castle i did not get the town
beforehand maybe i can go back i don't
know
i don't have to do it the whole game too
much pressure
more windows to break now beautiful okay
and let's break on this side no all
right let's go
we're gonna make her less hot is all i'm
saying
okay this seems fine seems like it'll be
perfectly normal great time for all
involved me looking for my daughter who
is definitely not here
maybe um
rose they turned you into a knife
how could they yeah
you've ruined everything
oh that's a shame seemed like that was
good maybe that might help
oh there it is
more of a bat okay
hey i'll go without makeup on am i right
so i'm just leaving
okay well
looks like you're outside matches your
inside
okay well thank you for that
oh great ah okay
sniper rifle [ __ ] is it can i walk
across that i can
okay i'm just not ready to use the
sniper yet and i didn't upgrade it
at all
we should run we should run i think
yeah it wasn't really worth it if i'm
being honest i don't i like the other
one better can we go back to that
and you seem to be handling things very
well
in that palm as well it's not like you
need this advantage i don't think
oh god
well i don't know that they were even
yours really
okay
jesus okay
i think i missed that one ah
what am i supposed to do about the bugs
oh my god
is there some kind of
running away from them doesn't seem
smart no no i don't mean to do any of
that
oh am i out of oh no i can't relate
oh god okay let's close
she's everywhere at once
you sound like you're inside of my soul
okay
that didn't hit me okay
no i'm not if i eat me driving
miss that
okay nothing good
nope nope nope not good not good just
almost good just seemed good but it
wasn't actually
i don't even know what i thought i was
doing that shot
i don't think the tail is has any
actual collision
fly off again this would have been done
so much easier if you just
foster if you just actually chased me
oh my god you don't ever need to
actually fly away you could just
like step on me a little bit and i'd be
there
why what do you need from her what
specifically is it about her that makes
me your only hook we can maybe we could
come to a deal i don't even like her
that much she's indicative of a shitty
mom
you can take a lot of hits my left
okay
i just can't help it hey queen
hey queen
this is all pretty gross um
all right yep with higher now
i see that i see that
where did you go though
[ __ ] how can i even miss you you're
that big
reload reload reload over
seems like a good call
oh that's
rose again
uh
you hate to see it okay
you're the one who's cursed nice ethan
yeah good timing on that it was a sick
insult dude you [ __ ] you showed her
am i limping now about time anything
hurt him
though i do think it's going to tie into
the plot i think it's i think it's plot
relevant i'm pretty convinced
um wow okay well there's that i guess
mia is it rose
maybe the rose they put her in this tiny
container how did they do that to you
okay it's like i'm getting out of this
place did i get everything in that room
though i didn't
so how about now i did okay
yikes oh my that was uh
that was a lot let's just give you some
health ethan
you can craft it it's it's been a while
you craft lots of stuff
that's fine let's just do this for now
we need another one no um and then find
somewhere to save hopefully
sheesh
typewriter oh here we go
all right everyone we're gonna leave it
there that was a lot i'm
sad um
but satisfied at the same time which you
know it's the best review you can hope
for